all right tonight yet another example
left-wing violence the same radical
group offering bounties for the
locations of any conservative supreme
court justice they're now attempting to
shut down the congressional baseball
game according to this group no
republican deserves peace ever again
senator rand paul no stranger himself to
violent agitators has been attacked at
least twice including one instance right
after the rnc convention when his the
senator and his wife surrounded by
far-left lunatics and rioters i barely
got out of there with his life
and of course the incident with the
neighbor here now is kentucky senator
rand paul
you know senator i know i know
washington dc is not far off from new
york in terms of their lack of
willingness to prosecute people that are
violent at least in kentucky
the guy that attacked you as i
understand it paid a price right
ultimately initially a clinton judge
gave him one month which is what you
might get for shoplifting came back
later and another democrat appointed
judge but a more fair-minded democrat
appointed judge gave him another eight
months so he got nine months but we
still have our major newspapers both the
louisville courier and the lexington
herald writing op-eds saying that it was
justified the attack on me was justified
and that i deserved it because i'm
somehow a provocative person that my
interviewing and my style of
interviewing fauci and others is
provocative and therefore i deserve
violence they're still saying that in
the newspaper one of our newspapers
employed a young man who tried to
assassinate the mayor mayoral candidate
of louisville
he got two days in prison and he was
released the black lives matter bailed
him out after two days and he worked for
the louisville courier we now have a new
writer for the lorokura who's been
arrested for violent assault and now
he's writing that the violence against
me was justified but he's previously
been convicted of assault also so yeah
the left wing is egging this on and if
we want it to end we've got to lock
people up the violent people need to be
put away for as long as we can put them
away
it seems like okay in real time i was on
the radio on january 6 i condemned what
was happening i condemned it that night
on this show
and yet in the summer 2020 your
democratic colleagues were either
completely silent because it was their
base that was involved in the looting
the rioting the arson
the attacks on police thousands of cops
injured dozens dead billions in property
damage
574 riots very few prosecutions in this
case even though we have a wealth of
evidence
we're the democrats that are lecturing
us on the need for safety and security
uh on the one riot why aren't they
speaking out against the 574 other riots
where's that committee think about that
think about this in a woman in her 60s
who's getting cancer treatment
wanders into the capital during all this
wanders out doesn't harm anybody is not
involved with violence and she gets
longer in prison
than the
you know people trying to assassinate a
candidate get or you know it's just
amazing what we're doing and who we're
letting off of this but ultimately
there's going to come a day of reckoning
where the people who live in new york
city crime disproportionately affects
those in poorer neighborhoods and those
who are minorities one day they're going
to rise up and say we've had enough the
democrats are not protecting our
children kids are dying at the bus stop
kids are dying on the subway the
democrats don't care about your kids and
it continues to happen decade after
decade there's going to be a day that
people are going to wake up and say
we've had enough we're going to vote for
law and order and lee zeldin is the law
and order candidate so i think there is
a chance that people will say i don't
care black white whatever i'm not
associated with any party i want a stop
to the crime and we have to put people
in jail i think that's coming
i think a big i think a big pushback is
coming on a lot of issues including we
need law we need order we need safety
and security to pursue happiness uh
parents want reading writing math
science and computers in school they
don't want uh let's see whatever politic
whatever political agenda is being
rammed down kids throats and they also
want lower gas prices and elimination of
the inflation record high that we have
not hard uh senator we're glad you're
safe thank you for being with us hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else